hi steve kaufman here
today i'm going to talk about i often
get this question like how do you start
a language from scratch what is your
process to learn a language
uh by the way if you enjoy my
podca or at least videos about language
learning please subscribe all right
how do you start from scratch obviously
right now i'm focusing on four slavic
languages
i've
studied all those four languages to
varying degrees before so i'm not
starting from scratch in fact the last
language i started from scratch
i guess was ukrainian but i had had
slavic languages before romanian maybe
how do i start from scratch all right
let's say i was going to study turkish
all right
or arabic and i do intend to do that one
day
i would go out and buy a starter book a
starter book is like a teach yourself
asi mill
colloquial any of those it almost
doesn't matter i just find it's
comfortable to have
a book a little book that gives you a
bit of an overview of the language
there's typically you know 20 or
12 chapters that introduce some aspects
of the language in each chapter they
have a dialogue some audio
some explanations
and i kind of go through them
predominantly to get a sense of the
language
to read some to get an overview of the
grammar
not expecting to remember
much
it's just kind of an introduction get my
feet wet so to speak
then as soon as i could i would get into
interesting content how soon i can get
into interesting content will depend on
the language
but i would start trying and i would do
that link obviously because there i can
look up every word i can save words i'm
used to that that's my favorite sort of
learning environment but my my sort of
modus operandi is to get into a
situation where i can listen and read
because
listening in combination with reading is
so powerful and so for an initial
six months or so
i would only
and so then people say well how can you
listen to things you don't understand
i get that all the time how can you
listen if you don't know the words
obviously when you start out you have to
listen to short bits of content because
you don't understand and you have to
listen to content where you have the
transcript and again it should be 30
seconds long because you're going to be
looking up words you're going to be
struggling you don't understand you're
in that early process of discovering the
language but to listen to something you
have to have the transcript so that you
can look up the words all right also
listening and reading go together why
because we listen to something that has
been recorded all right that's a record
it's an audio record of something that
someone said but writing is a written
record before they had
you know tape recorders
or mp3 files all he had was writing that
was the only way to record what was said
and the writing is a visual
representation of the words i find that
i need both if i just hear it i won't
remember it not a chance uh if i'm
talking to my tutor and she gives me a
new word in ukrainian if i don't see it
written down i haven't got a chance of
remembering that word but if i hear it
often enough and see it often enough
that's the visual representation if i
combine the two i have a chance of
accumulating those words so in order for
that to work in the initial period which
might be one two three months you've
gotta
listen more than once to the same
content so that's what i would do
therefore it has to be short
and you have to
even though the content is
boring it's the challenge of trying to
make sense out of this new language that
makes it interesting enough stimulating
challenging enough that i can actually
listen over and over because i'm still
not getting certain parts of it even
though i
read it and i've looked up the words and
i've kind of
pieced together what it means when i
listen to it is still a blur so
therefore there's that challenge that
keeps you focused you're going to listen
to it again read it again and also in
the beginning i'm more likely to review
words and phrases
using my flashcards or other of the
activities that we have at link
closed tests or multiple choice or
whatever
to try to somehow because i have to very
sort of intensively work this stuff
because it's so new to me
now gradually as i progress
and and remember again i'm listening to
content that's short
for which i have the transcript and
hopefully it's relatively easy because
it's designed for beginners
and we have you can get that out of your
beginner book you can find lots of such
content at link for different languages
some languages have more than others and
then but as early as possible i want to
get to interesting content because after
a while it becomes boring to listen to
stuff that's essentially boring so i
have to move to a stage where i'm now
motivated by my interest
in the content and for me very often
that means books related to the history
of the country
where the language is spoken
and then it continues it's that
combination of the the sound and the
visual representation of the words
repeated repeated repeated now some
people say well you should you know try
and first learn the
most important 1000 words of the
language they will show up anyway that
you needn't worry about
the main thing is is to get hooked
hooked on the language get enough of a
start with the beginner material that
you've got a bit of a toe hold on more
interesting material
and initially it's a tough grind but
i find that in that early period where
it's very difficult and i'm looking up a
lot of words i'm excited by the fact
that i'm actually reading and listening
to authentic material that turns me on
wow look at me now i've got say a
turkish
[Music]
newscast with transcript and i'm
listening to it not really understanding
it reading it listening again but it's
real stuff and then
sort of without even realizing it all of
a sudden three months later
i'm able to understand more and more of
these podcasts or whatever they might be
and and then as i'm getting more and
more of the meaning
then i try to notice
expressions
or words that are kind of key
words for the meaning or key words that
i would like to use and so i think it's
useful once you are comfortable
with the meaning that you try to focus
on certain expressions when you notice
them certain phrases all right
the great thing about listening is you
can do it wherever you are i find that
and i've said this before
if i just sit down and listen i lose
focus however if i'm listening while
driving if i'm listening while doing the
dishes then i seem to be able to focus
in better on the meaning and
once you are able to kind of get the
meaning fairly well
that's the time where you start focusing
in on expressions and phrases so that
you notice it here you notice that
they're in pretty soon it starts to
become part of your uh
of your vocabulary now
in my different people start speaking at
different times
i if i were doing turkish i would
imagine that my initial period with the
beginner material might be three months
because it's a totally different
language
then i might go another three four five
months with a lot of listening and
reading getting into more and more
interesting content and then i would
need to start speaking because when you
start speaking you see things that are
missing you get a report back hopefully
from your tutor which i can import in
the link
and this increases your attentiveness so
that when you're listening you're
listening for some of the things that
you have had difficulty with and and as
you progress you're able to speak more
but even when i'm speaking a lot like
right now with my ukrainian because i'm
doing four languages are doing ukrainian
for six weeks then i'm gonna do maybe
polish and maybe czech
so i'm speaking once a day an hour a day
that's a lot i think it's sufficient to
do it once or twice a week that's all
the speaking you need in order to
to
kind of maintain that level of focus
when you're listening and reading
and basically that's what i do if i have
dedicated learning time i sit down with
my ipad and i read and i create links
uh the listening ends up being the
biggest part of my learning activity
because i can i can do it whenever i
want but that basically is what i would
do so when i undertake turkish or arabic
when i get around to doing that i would
expect that it would take me a year
on you know using mostly listening time
maybe 45 minutes a day an hour another
half hour uh with my ipad on link on
that basis i would think within a year i
would be able to uh present to you some
videos of me uh speaking turkish
that's for the future anyway that's a
brief description of how i go about
learning languages i hope this was of
interest and i'd be interested in
answering any questions
bye for now
[Music]
you